(host)
First impression
of the now-classic "Cujo"--
a mother's fight
to save her son's life
while being terrorized
by a rabid dog
blocking her escape.
Second impression:
"Cujo" is a modern-day
hellhound,
guarding the threshold between
the dead inside the house
and the mom clinging
to her son's life outside.
Hellhounds are mostly
black-furred and startling,
with red, glowing eyes,
employed by a leader
of the afterlife.
Take the terror dogs
from "Ghostbusters,"
servants of Gozer,
the all-powerful entity
from another dimension
who ruled over a dark,
underground realm of souls.
Vinz Clortho, the Keymaster,
and Zuul, the Gatekeeper,
take the form of horned,
red-eyed hellhounds on Earth.
Tasked with guarding
the entrance
to a literal hell gate
to Gozer's realm,
they are an iconic anomaly
in modern popular culture
for their unusual ability
to possess humans.
Even hardcore dog lovers
would be hard-pressed
to call these canines "cuties."
The hounds of hell
may not try to sink their fangs
into your flesh
or tear you limb from limb--
every time--
but your eternal life
is entirely up for grabs.
So, are dogs
man's best friend
or underworld enforcers?
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka,
and this is "Monstrum."
I'm using "hellhound" here
as an overarching term
to refer to preternatural
canine creatures
who are associated with
the afterlife or underworld.
Many dogs in early folklore
and mythology
are connected to these places,
but that isn't to say that
they were all inherently evil.
In some ways,
early death dogs
were guides and protectors.
Take Anubis, the jackal
or jackal-headed Egyptian god
of the dead and mummification,
who protected the resting place
of the physical body
and guided the soul
to the afterlife.
Similarly,
Shyama and Sabala
were Hindi hounds who guarded
the gods of death's gates,
each with two sets of eyes--
the better to protect you.
Cerberus, the three-headed hound
who guards Hades,
keeps the souls
sequestered there
and keeps the heroes out.
He can be a good boy, though.
I mean, he adorably
falls into a slumber
if you play him
a little music,
which you might want to do,
since otherwise,
he could just eat you.
In Mesoamerican
spiritual beliefs,
in some Latin American
traditions,
dogs guide the souls
of the dead to the next world.
And if you mistreated
a dog in life,
in death your soul was at risk
to wander for eternity.
In various Middle Eastern
and Indian traditions,
dogs were the escorts
into the afterlife,
brought into the room
of a dying person
to shepherd their passing.
But these hounds aren't
inherently evil or scary.
Why is it all hound
and no hell?
Funny you should ask.
In Nordic sagas,
there's Garmr,
a bloodstained hellhound.
His mistress was
the death goddess Hel,
who presided
over the underworld,
and his howl is said to signal
the beginning of Ragnarök.
We also start to see the line
between guardian and menace
blur as BCE turns to CE.
Influential Roman poet Horace
wrote of a "dark companion,"
a "black dog" who symbolizes
misfortune and despair.
Greek philosopher
and historian Plutarch
went so far
as to call dogs "impure"
because of their association
with the goddess Hecate,
who sacrificed dogs to serve
as guides for souls
in the afterlife.
The goddess herself
was even referred to
as a "black female dog."
Mosaics in Ancient Greece
show ferocious black dogs
guarding
the entrance to homes--
the earliest precursors
to "Beware of Dogs" signs.
In the first
and second century CE,
dogs were incorporated
into folklore
as harbingers of misfortune,
which, given their close
relationship with humans
and the potential
to be aggressive,
made them easy targets.
With the rise
of the Medieval period,
as we begin to separate
the animal from Homo sapiens,
dogs continue to be demonized,
but also commonly prized
as loyal companions
and working animals.
In Medieval
Middle Eastern culture,
dogs were considered dirty,
disease-ridden creatures,
and all roots for the word "dog"
have negative connotations,
like "rabid" or "crazed."
Nevertheless, like the earlier
social and spiritual roles
of canines across the world,
they could also be guard dogs
or domestic helpers.
The liminality of the dog
as inside/outside,
helper/harmer
in equal measure,
parallels the boundary
between life and death.
Much like life and death,
we both fear and revere canines.
So, a supernatural version
of an everyday animal
spanning that threshold
kind of makes sense.
Darkness is associated
with obscurity,
representing
more negative connotations
than positive ones,
and why many of
these hellhounds were described
and depicted with black fur.
In Medieval Europe,
black canines
appear in medical texts,
associated with melancholia
and other illnesses.
In one 1800s CE French text,
it is written that one
could determine if a person
was terminally ill by taking
a tick from a black dog
and holding it
in the left hand.
If one presented
to a gravely ill person,
they turn toward it--
they're a goner.
Black dogs continued to be
associated with illness
centuries later.
Even in the late 18th century,
the black dog is linked
to depression.
This terminology lingered into
the 19th and 20th centuries,
where bad moods
were attributed
to having a "black dog"
on one's back
or worrying you at home.
Winston Churchill
would reportedly refer
to his own struggles
with depression
as his "black dog."
Here on "Monstrum,"
we know that Christianity
loved to adopt and distort
older spiritual beliefs
and folkloric traditions,
especially
to support its agenda.
So it's not
all that surprising
the devil entered the equation,
taking the hellhounds
of folkloric traditions
and pre-Abrahamic
spiritual practices
into the devil
and witchcraft game.
Animals often serve
to normalize the supernatural
by marrying it
to something non-human
but still in the realm
of tangible familiarity.
Connecting demonic possession
with an animal
represented the beastly
or primal desire
of the human animal.
And, as we know, primal desires
are a no-no for the church.
In the 1574
demonic possession case
of English lawyer
Robert Briggs,
a demonic dog
plays a central figure.
Described
as horrifically ugly,
with a shaggy,
blackish-red coat,
the dog would reportedly
follow Briggs around London.
Briggs himself was terrified
of the monster,
and at one point,
even jumped into the Thames
to shake the creature.
The dog was said to be
an earthly manifestation
of the devil himself.
Other possession accounts
from the 16th century
include symptoms such as
sounding like a hellhound,
acting like a wild dog,
or communicating with dogs.
In a case
at the turn of the century,
the devil communed with
his victim, William Sommers,
in the form
of a talking black dog.
Hellhounds seem to be
primarily associated
with transient spaces,
whether those are spaces
of physical travel and movement,
like roadways and gates,
or places of
metaphysical transformation--
graveyards or execution sites,
for instance.
English folk culture
is perhaps where this trend
is most obvious,
but it's by no means exclusive.
Great Britain, Ireland,
France, Scandinavia, Germany--
all of these place tell tales
of the black dog--
a special variation
of the hellhound trope
distinguished
by its massive red eyes
and long, thick,
black coat
whose presence always foretells
death and disaster
for those who see it.
Wandering spirits
and lost souls
are often said to take
the form of spectral dogs.
In German lore, they appear
as shaggy dogs with black fur
and unnaturally glowing eyes.
Although,
in a unique quirk,
if any specific breed is noted
in the description
of these German creatures,
it's often the poodle.
Seems a bit odd,
unless you know that the poodle
traces its heritage
back to Germany
where they were bred
as duck-hunters.
Ghost dogs with black coats
and red eyes are reported
all across England,
sometime under the name
"black shuck"--
a regional variation
of the black-dog motif
specific to the eastern
countryside of England.
The monster is said to be
a demonic being,
either a hound from hell,
a demon familiar,
or both.
It may be accompanied
by a foul smell.
Shuck comes from "Shucky,"
a local term
for hairy or shaggy,
or the Old English word
for "demon."
Some scholars connect
the black shuck
and other demonic dogs
in England
to the legend
of the wild hunt--
a spectral hunting party that
seeks the souls of the living,
the first written account
of which appears in 1127.
The first written recording
of the black shuck, however,
appears in 1577.
According to this early legend,
during mass at an Anglican
church in Blythburgh,
a clap of thunder rang out
before the doors to the church
slammed open,
revealing a giant black dog
who tore through the building,
killing two people before
causing the steeple to collapse.
That same day,
another church in Bungay
experienced a black shuck
visit as well.
The same dog
stormed into the building
accompanied by lightning,
clamping onto the necks of
two congregants, killing them.
The floors of both churches
bore scorch marks
where the dog's paws
had touched--
ones that some swear
can still be seen today.
Unsurprisingly, the dog
was associated with the Devil.
The prevalence of black dogs
in British folklore,
literature, and oral tradition
from the 17th century onward
is responsible for dominating
popular culture's understanding
of spectral hounds.
Take the 18th century case
of the old woman
and the chimneysweep
from Hertfordshire, England.
As the story goes,
an old woman was drowned
for her suspected use
of witchcraft--
a murderous deed carried out
by a chimneysweeper
who himself was publicly hanged
near the spot.
After this second death,
a black dog appeared
in the area.
As big as a Newfoundland
but malnourished,
the shaggy, black-haired
creature's long teeth
protruded
from his grinning mouth,
his eyes glowing
like balls of fire.
Despite
his frightening appearance,
the creature never did more
than suddenly appear,
giving unsuspecting travelers
a fright.
In Lincolnshire,
a taller and thinner version
of the black dog appears
near a deep pond
surrounded by trees.
Water has long been associated
with liminality.
Ponds, rivers, wells,
and even puddles
could be portals
to the otherworld,
and the dangerous nature
of all bodies of water
links them to death.
Some rationalize sightings
of these monsters
as culturally based fear
responses to stressful events--
eerie nighttime encounters,
death,
or destructive thunderstorms.
Others say the sightings
can be attributed
to panthers or large cats
that escape from
private residences and zoos.
Some insist the sulfur smell
that may accompany the black dog
is not the sign
of a hellish origin,
but the result
of hydrogen sulfide gas
produced by the rotting
vegetation of the wetlands,
where many of the sightings
took place.
The boom of published
folklore collections
in the 19th century
also meant hellhounds
began to pop up again
in fictional literature.
Famous Victorian texts
like "Jane Eyre,"
"The Hound of Baskervilles,"
and "Dracula"
solidified the presence
of monster dogs
in 19th century
Gothic literature.
In more modern
literature and film,
the idea of hellhounds
and spectral dogs of all sorts
has become more varied.
They've played tribute
to ancient Greek mythology
and continue to serve
as metaphors of ill omen,
but they've also appeared
as happy ghost hounds
and lovable spirit guides.
These varied
and various representations
display our changing view
of canines
and, arguably,
our renewed appreciation
for older traditions.
So, despite modern society's
infatuation with puppers,
doggos, and booping
the snout of fluffers,
we can't seem
to fully remove the dog
from the hellhound.
Nrhh.
Look it up.
Hertfordshire, England!
I don't think there's
any reason to add the "D,"
I'm just doing it.
It's probably "Briggs."
Briggs.
Hertfordshire. Perfect.